der schauspieler fabian hinrichs hat für
die spielbahnen änderung das stück seit
einer tal von lord byron ausgewählt er
sagt das ist ein stück des augenblicks
was er damit meint und warum das stück
unbedingt auf die bühne sollte darüber
spreche ich leicht mit dem autor und
dramaturgen carl hegemann
er hat jahrelang unter castorf an der
volksschule gearbeitet und er ist einer
der wenigen kenner des stücks wir
treffen uns hier im wunderschönen
restaurant jolesch denn könig sah danach
hall die hauptfigur des stücks ist ein
genießer des schönen lebens der
gaumenfreuden und des exzesses deswegen
wollen wir auch gleich ordentlich
schlemmen während wir über das stück
sprechen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das grün der savanne
er will nicht vorgefertigte ihm
aufgedruckte rollen erfüllen berufe
ausbildung eine laufbahn ein
lebensvollzug umsetzen sondern er möchte
lieber ein glas wein trinken
die neuwahl entlang gondeln mit seiner
großen liebe
er möchte sich dessen gesagt werden dass
das leben doch eine kette von
augenblicken ist
denn fabian schmidt mit blumen und
lampen aus und richtig in mir her um
dort ein festliches bankett zu halten um
mitternacht sollen getafelt werden sie
zu dass es am nichts uns fehlen die
schönen nymphen ihr lieb und holt die
sanften stunden mit mitteilen wollen in
jener süßesten sehen wir uns wieder und
schaden uns wie jene sterne dort dann
schafft ihr ein himmel mir der strahl
wie jener dort ist das hätte er sei dann
ab als auch gemacht
giulia man versteht ist ja warum nicht
warum nicht gleich beim frühstück
anfangen
[Musik]
der 45-jährige dramaturgen karriere habe
ich so ein stück nicht gesehen dass ein
könig nach 1300 jahren herrschaft
geschichte und eroberung halber er teile
am ende dieser semira misst dynastie auf
die dick und seinem volk nur ein
einziges gesetz zu geben und das heißt
dann isst trinkt und lieb alles andere
ist keinen heller wert das ist ja formal
bemerkenswert ich anerkenne dein
verdienst die städter asko wohl aber aus
einer laune heraus
jetzt geht der bau die geschichte ein
durch einen vers der dir und ihnen ewig
schade bringt mir schon üblich war so
gut gebaut die städte sind ist besser
doch mein vertrag ich mich um eine
lebensart was du willst doch hast die
wahrheit mir von diesem kurzen satz ich
diese zeilen steht ja die geschichte der
menschheit
[Musik]
ahnatal
der könig er baut an einem tage ans
jallohs und tages 1 ich trink und liebt
der rest ist kein meiler werde ich
würdige moral und weiser rat mit der
ankündigt spricht zu seinen untertanen
du hättest ohne zweite schreiben lassen
preußenkönig märz ein reichtum helfen
und blutet wenn ich ihn vielleicht auch
so einschlug sonderfall und an dieser
stelle
zigtausend seine feinde tut dies hier
ist die gräber sein triumph ich lasse
den ober ein solches zeugen wir selbst
genügt habe meine untertanen ich weniger
füllen lassen
also es gibt ein könig der nicht nur
sagt ich fresse nur noch und saufen nur
noch ich habe sowieso die schnauze voll
von politik sondern der sagt alle so
dass dieses recht haben ich bin kein
stück in dem menschen sich so schnell so
gut ändern können und das ist ja
vielleicht auch ein bisschen was was
heute an unserer gesellschaft auch ein
bisschen abhanden kommt diese diese
bereitschaft sich auch von einem guten
argument überzeugen zu lassen
die bereitschaft ist ja offenbar weg
dabei gibt es vielleicht kann man das
sogar in dem stück lernen
es gibt doch im grunde genommen nichts
besseres wie wenn ein gesprächspartner
kommt und ein argument hat dass die
eigenen argumente widerlegt ich kann es
einfach nicht verstehen warum die leute
sich nicht freuen wenn der andere recht
hat sowieso japan hier ist ein helfer
der ist klar erfolge der helfer aber er
will kein herrscher sein manchmal geht
es doch noch mit ihm los dann ist er als
hätte er hamas gewesen lässt er sich von
dem zwanglosen zwang des besseren
arguments sofort überzeugen und das ist
natürlich eine art von erwachsenen haid
die bei diesem eigentlich spiel kennt
muss mich erst mal sehr überraschend ist
und damit hat es formal inhaltlich eine
qualität die ein gutes theater auf der
karte haben muss nämlich dass es
widersprüchlich ist und dass die
charaktere nicht eindimensional
gezeichnet sind es zeigt die völlige
ambivalenz des modernen menschen der
gleichzeitig wert legt auf seine
einzigartigkeit und auf die gleichheit
aller menschen und in diesem brief bald
also er möchte vom was ganz besonderes
sein
aber er möchte da hatte er sagt diese
besonderheit von mir ist nichts wenn
nicht alle auch besonders ein können
[Musik]
so wunderbar geschäft kam es fast dem
herzen noch zuvor
es rief nach der und sie du kommst ein
unsichtbares band verbindet und was ist
es wohl in meinem vater landes ist ein
gott in meinem herzen ein gefühl wir
haben scheint und doch ist sterblich nur
ich weiß denn was ich fühle dass demut
doch auch glück das heißt glück könnt
seine doch ist tritt doch immer etwas
zwischen uns und unser glück lasst mich
die schranke heben die deine zunge
zögern lässt
woher mein für ein könig meist so heißt
es immerzu in erfurt voller rede nie see
ein lächerlich als manchmal nur im
rausch der feste oder ich höre diese
namen her könig führt und schätze sie
entsetzt das heißt ich habe sie ertragen
doch fallen sie von lippen dich liebt
kommt über mich an kalk gefühl der
falschheit meiner position die das
gefühl in denen unterdrückt für die
meisten nicht gefühlt dass das ruft in
mir den wunsch hervor
die dumme krone abzutun ein kleines haus
mit dir zu teilen
keine krone mehr zu tragen als die von
blumen nur er ist kein moralist und er
ist kein selbst probte optimierer und
die hohle billigere moral die geht im
ganzen ab vorbei und das insofern ist
das ein figuren der man sich abarbeiten
kann
sie funktioniert ganz anders sie
funktioniert fast wie ein gegenmodell zu
den modellen die wir gerade im umlauf
haben und jetzt kriegen wir das wiener
schnitzel
[Musik]
das ist ja können dann glauben sie dass
hätte santana teil hier gefallen
also ich glaube von das hätte ihm sehr
gut gefallen aber nach sechs stunden
gelage wäre es nicht wieder zu erkennen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]